i'm now going to show you a video from
california so i do have to put money in
the jar but this is actually quite
spectacular this is a californian mother
her name is erin friday and she's a
lefty she's a liberal she'll make the
point in just a moment
and she has basically had it with what's
going on related to all of the gender
nonsense and the fact that gavin newsom
psychopath gavin newsom wants california
to become a gender sanctuary state so
that kids in other
states can move there to have their
genitals and boobs cut off take a look
hi my name's aaron friday i'm a democrat
and i voted for same-sex marriage
i'm one of the leads of our duty and
parents of our ogd kids there are
thousands of parents in our group
we are cheering on the states that are
starting stopping gender medicine on
children
parents in the state of california have
lost custody of their children merely by
calling their child by their legal name
sb 107 must not pass
custody is one of the hardest fought
aspects of a divorce and california
cannot just wipe away an out-of-state
agreement addressing which parent
controls the medical health of a child
scott weiner a man without children is
pushing gender affirmative medicine laws
for minors while other countries are
moving away from the affirmation model
look to sweden
finland norway the uk and france
you need to be
100 percent confident that sterilizing
children is truly life-saving
the number of kids going to gender
clinics is skyrocketing
in the uk
it is a 5
000
uptick
for girls as seen in the graph
it's the same here
we parents know it's a social contagion
as we watch clusters of friend groups
come out as trans
it's not organic
if trans medicine prevents suicide
why then as trans medicine gets more
prevalent are more girls committing
suicide
why are they suffering from severe
depression
engaging in self-harm
this gene twinged graph of suicide and
self-harm matches the trans medicine
trajectory
laura edwards lieber who brought
pediatric gender care to the united
states says and i quote there are no
studies that say that it
that if we don't start these kids
immediately on hormones when they say
that they want them that they are going
to commit suicide
the long-term effects of puberty
blockers and cross-sex hormones is
largely unknown
what is known
is that bone density and brain
development is adversely affected
ma'am respectfully if you could please
wrap up
your times have been exceeded marcy
bowers a trans woman and current
president of wpath on the effect of
puberty blockers on biological males
says and i quote
every single child who is blocked at
standard page stage two has never
experienced an orgasm i mean it's zero
these young men are also rendered
irreversibly sterile
don't make california a refuge for what
will be seen as the largest medical
scandal in history
educate yourself
thank you
okay so there's obviously some serious
stuff here but the funny stuff first the
guy who is pushing this in california
he's a representative congressman a
democrat of course and as she said his
name is scott
weiner
the man who is creating a sanctuary
state for people young children to come
and get their wieners chopped off is
named weiner
okay you see what's going on here uh
joking aside um this woman as she points
out she's a democrat so she's been
misguided politically let's say but she
voted for same-sex marriage she's
obviously not a bigot she is not a
racist person or a right-wing maniac or
alt-right she's probably not a trump
supporter or anything else she is a
liberal who has been mugged by reality
which is pretty much everyone in america
right now right all of the sort of
middle people who just thought oh the
liberalism the decent liberalism that we
had for these last 50 60 100 years in
america
if not more actually was going to just
keep working it has morphed into
something horrific and that thing that
it has morphed into is now fully and
wholly infected the democrat party which
is a why a guy by the name of scott
weiner
is now pushing for california to be a
sanctuary state for kids to come and
have their gender change and of course
you cannot actually change your gender
you can change your body but you cannot
change uh your
you cannot change your sex your
biological sex oh interestingly i'm just
seeing this right now thanks for the
heads up on this aaron friday that woman
right there her daughter de-transitioned
meaning her daughter
transitioned to become a boy and then at
some point along the road actually now
went back to being a girl uh she also
brings up these incredible numbers these
staggering staggering statistics of this
explosion of mostly
young girls that are becoming boys and
it usually is not young boys becoming
girls there are some instances of that
five thousand percent increase
in the uk i mean this is extraordinary
stuff this is a social contagion much
more than a biological uh inconsistency
or problem and everyone understands it
and the fact that you would do this to
children